if you're, you know, if you're, if you're, you know, you're, you've done your appeals,
like you said, stay on top of the appeals. Like when I was doing it, I mean, every two,
three days I was sending those assholes an appeal. I was appeal, appeal, appeal.
And eventually someone, someone responded to me eventually because I was like, well,
this is ridiculous. And I think in some other people in the past that have had suspensions,
like that's kind of been some of the secret sauce for them is they have just been on top of it.
They're not letting a week or two go by. They go back and find that email and that link and they
click it and they send it. And even though they send you another one, like, yeah, we got you.
You're like, yeah, no, I'm doing that again. And then you do it again. You're like, nope,
I'm doing it again. I'm going to be the squeaky wheel. Here I go. Because like you said,
you're telling them I'm not a scammer. I am a person. I'm not doing this because imagine how
much spam they get every day. Right. And that's, that's a deterrent for them. Because if I'm just
trying to run a hundred thousand accounts and I'm just trying to see what sticks, like I'm not
coming back to that, but if I'm a person running a business, I'm coming back to that. I'm going,
Hey man, what about my business account? What about my business account? And then the finally,
they're like, okay, this person is responding and you might, you hopefully get moved up in
priority to get a response.